okay let's speak to the audience welcome
welcome you can speak to me at
davidpackman.com Discord very easy you
join the waiting Lobby
and you raise your hand and we are going
to start today with oh I don't know how
about Mark from Los Angeles mark from
Los Angeles welcome to the program uh
what is on your mind today I am uh
thrilled to have you with us
oh boy mark from Los Angeles I've
invited you on but you've got to accept
or it is going to go bye-bye
and there is Mark from Los Angeles
losing the opportunity that's really too
bad let's try Jack from Connecticut Jack
from Connecticut what's going on my
friend
all right Jack from Connecticut has
accepted the invitation but has the
wrong audio device selected oh fantastic
welcome Jack now I can hear you okay
fantastic
um you can hear me yes I can all right
well good afternoon David thank you very
much for having me on again I wanted to
bring I wanted to bring up an
interesting topic that's happening in
about uh two days time okay so in two
days time the Republican National
Committee will select um we'll have its
uh leadership election yes and uh for
the first time in about 10 years there
will be more than one candidate those
candidates are uh
incumbent Rana McDaniel Mike Lindell
unfortunately and the former National
Committee woman for California and I
just wanted to know um if you've been
following the story and if you had any
uh thoughts to share well I support
pillow in this race I have absolutely no
stake whatsoever and no involvement in
Republican Party politics but it just
seems to me that Mike pillow being RNC
chair would be the most humiliating
thing to the Republican party so that's
what I'm in favor of now I couldn't tell
you uh Jack because I haven't been
following it whether pillow has any shot
whatsoever like it from what you know
could he end up being RNC chair
um I mean given the fact that we all
know the Deep division that is running
rampant in the Republican party yeah
um I my personal guess is either
McDaniel or Mike Lindell honestly at
this point because
realistically I don't think the National
Conference will select um a committee
woman from a deep blue State interesting
well we we are going to see I I hope
it's pillow just for the memes and the
lulls and I know that that's a very
inappropriate way to analyze it but it's
like I I hope they destroy themselves
you know
yeah it's honestly something that the
Republican party needs to realize and
wake up to because if they really want
to re reshape themselves if they even
had an image in the first place they
really need to think about things like
they ever would yeah pillow as your RNC
chair is not exactly a signal that
you're sort of can that you're taking
seriously the destruction that Maga has
done to your party
exactly but it was just it was just an
interesting topic that I wanted to bring
up and uh thank you for taking my call
my pleasure Jack from Connecticut we
will watch the election results very
very closely let's go to Thai from Iowa
Ty from Iowa welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey David this is my second time calling
in all right well let's make sure it's
not the last okay
all right so um I just wanted to ask um
do you think it's kind of weird that um
that um so many people kind of list
lists countries like China North Korea
as Communists when they really don't fit
the
the uh what's what is it like the the
definition they would have to be a yeah
the definition they would have to be
like you know a country of no class
money or state you know all that stuff
yeah I mean I don't know that I agree
with you completely in the sense that
um communist and socialist uh countries
it's it's not uncommon that it's sort of
like communistic or socialistic for most
people but then through corruption and
cronyism there actually is an upper
class that that I don't think that alone
makes it not actually communist or
socialist but you know for me it's less
about is North Korea actually communist
then
um focusing in on the specific human
rights abuses and and just completely
insane familial passing of power that
exists and yeah I don't concern myself
much with whether they really meet this
or that it's sort of like when you do
the Jordan Peterson stuff where you try
to criticize something that Jordan
Peterson said and someone will come out
and say no you're not completely
accurately criticizing what he really
said you're criticizing something else
it's sort of like well you shouldn't
really criticize this as a communist
country because here's a way in which
it's not really communist I don't know I
don't get too involved in that really
yeah I understand that I think people
should just realized that I mean there
are people on the left that can be bad
and people on the right that can be bad
you know and I just uh but I don't know
I just kind of if you really kind of
look into it some people have argued
that North Korea would actually be
influenced by like Japanese fascism
instead of something like I don't know
like
like modern communism yeah listen I I
it's it's mostly moot because I think
for me it's let's identify the things
that are not going well and let's see if
we can improve on them for the benefit
of the people and there are many of
those things in North Korea that's for
sure
yeah that makes sense all right Ty from
Iowa thank you for the call
all right thank you for talking to you
again nerd pleasure